après on l'a appris ce week-end les
affaires judiciaires semblent
s'enchaîner pour patrick poivre d'arvor
l'ex journaliste star était déjà accusée
par l'écrivaine florence pour celle
d'aujourd'hui sont deux autres femmes
qui l'accusent respectivement de viols
et de harcèlement sexuel
il a été entendu la semaine dernière par
les enquêteurs bien sûr continue de nier
les faits patrick poivre d'arvor
aujourd'hui on se demandait ce qu'il
peut revenir ou est-ce que sa carrière
est terminée
regardez petit sujet sur europe 1 une
deux nouvelles plaintes contre patrick
poivre d'arvor à la première pour
harcèlement sexuel la plaignante aurait
subi des avances répétées de la part de
patrick poivre d'arvor la seconde pour
viol elle a été déposée par l'une des
anciennes assistantes de patrick poivre
d'arvor à tf1 et ex présentatrice de lci
hélène devynck une information du
parisien qui révèle aussi l'existence de
plusieurs messages échangés par florence
porcel la première femme à avoir porté
plainte contre ppda avec une romancière
lauréate d'un prix organisée par le
présentateur des messages dans lesquels
se mêlent des fantasmes de la
fascination pour l'ancien présentateur
mais aussi de la colère et quelques
accusations contre lui bernard montiel
est-ce que vous avez des nues
sincèrement je vais envoyer un mot
aujourd'hui ne va pas répondu donc je
pense qu'il doit être dans un sale état
évidemment tout ça est très dur ça s'est
passé mardi dernier où il a dû aller au
commissariat pour cette histoire
épouvantable c'est c'est pas clair là
les filles je ne veux pas je ne maîtrise
pas le dossier me le dire elles ont
échangé des mots
ces deux jeunes femmes qui ont porté
plainte contre lui elles ont échangé des
mots sur un compte à part où elle se
raconter leur nuit avec lui avec
fantasme etc etc etc
avec plein de fantasmes fantasme de
violer fantôme de punch aux
téléspectateurs c'est un de vos
meilleurs amis mais oui oui bien sûr
pour ça il faut le rappeler oui si vous
voulez bien sûr bien sûr
moi je les aime beaucoup et encore j'ai
envie de redire mac est justement le
connais bien je vais vous dire c'est un
homme s'est pas il est tellement
orgueilleux entre guillemets mais qui ne
peut pas forcer une personne à coucher
avec lui c'est un lourdaud c'est un gros
dragueur idrac toutes les nanas qui
passe mais de là au viol non ce n'est
pas dans sa mentalité
il veut séduire puisque un peu violence
pour celle qui est très sympathique
voilà et donc voilà qui a l'air normal
et hélène de 20 on se rappelle c'était
pendant six mois la sueur sur m6 voilà
que je crois une fois un truc était
aussi voilà c'est vrai que c'est ça a
l'air d'être des personnes sérieuses
c'est pour ça que aussi un sur six est
pris en compte c'est pas des voix lasse
et cesser de salaires des deux des deux
personnes les personnes mais c'était de
toute façon c'est une histoire
épouvantable a fait l'inversé des
personnes sérieuses qui a quand même
travaillé dans le groupe tf1 donc ça
veut dire on sait que dans le groupe tf1
j'ai l'impression qu'on veut pas trop en
parler ce qui est normal parce qu'en
terme d'image c'est un petit peu
compliqué donc ça veut dire que si elles
commencent à témoigner ouvertement
franchement je vois pas comment il va
s'en sortir après sur votre question
bien évidemment en terme d'image
personne ne peut reprendre patrick
poivre d'arvor ces morts qui soit
coupable ou pas et là il ya quand même
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de beaucoup
de doutes sur sur son innocence je le
vois pas comment il peut continuer moi
moi bernard mon problème c'est que j'ai
l'impression que tu es en train
d'oublier la notion dans prises par ces
femmes parce que bob peut-être deux par
ton amour pour cette personne que moi je
connais pas mais à partir du moment où
tu as quand même ont plein de femmes qui
commencent à se plaindre faut quand même
se pose se poser et réfléchir un petit
peu à ce qui se passe pour de vrai on
connaît jamais les gens tu sais alors
moi je suis pas besoin de l'accusé mais
il faut quand même prendre part des
discours de chaque personne parce que la
notion d'emprise elle peut quand même
être établie goyer guillot pour répondre
à la question sensible constaté que
depuis l'éclatement d'affaires pbd il
n'a plus aucune activité professionnelle
était consultant sur une chaîne belge on
n'a jamais revu à l'antenne dans
totalement absent des plateaux télé il
est également des ménages régulièrement
dans les entreprises notamment le terme
de la santé les entreprises ont
totalement arrêté ses collaborations
avec lui ont eu de lourdes répercussions
pour lui de suite à cette affaire
puisqu'il répond non à cause de moi qui
ai dit oui il ya des neiges
alors oui non moi j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour leurs larmes lorsqu'il a
bercé mon enfance le 20h tout ça mais
quand je vois votre vote il ya qu'ici il
ya que dans les médias et dans la télé
qu'on s'inquiète si sa carrière elle est
finie il est rincé la 73' réclamé 10 et
les carbonisé retraite tranquillement ta
les blindés se sont tu vas revenir porte
en quoi le loto qui s'est finie frères
ventes chez moi tranquillement
après il ya les enquêtes pénales donc
écrire qu'elle aille au bout alors parce
que c'est ton copain c'est bien mais
quand même quand il ya une femme deux
femmes trois femmes ça commence un peu
faut chercher faut voir s'il a fait des
bêtises
s'il a fait des bêtises poivre d'arvor
ou pas par audard voir faudra qu'ils
payent faudra qu'ils se mettent devant
la justice mais votre question à me fait
marrer c'est qu'ici à la carrière est
finie c'est 65 ans à près de 60 ans pour
les messins 13
il faut qu'ils reviennent pour quoi
faire
[Applaudissements]